[Music]
pubs there's thousands of them but this
story is about just four and what makes
them so special
derald this guy thinks his pub is oldest
and fair bit older our race no way I
guess we should look into this in that
case welcome to the search for the
oldest pub in the world take the floor
landlord one welcome to the old trip to
loosen the oldest pub in England so the
landlord boards go back to 1760 but we
know the caves go back to 1070 when the
first castle was built up here here is
the wooden galleon don't touch it though
everyone has cleaned it it's come to a
mysterious end who knows if for the
oldest pub in the world well we sure
serve the best pie in the world
[Music]
learn not to you're up welcome to the
old ferryboat the oldest pub in England
and possibly the world isn't oh the last
ghost air no no no it is right this pub
has been dated back to 1050 ad but
legend has it it's five hundred years
older so it's pretty old pretty damn old
we don't have any silly ships here but
we do have a ghost this pub was built on
the grave of a young girl for Juliet's
but one thing's for sure we do serve the
best point let's hear it landlord three
welcome to your man inside it's so old
we don't even know exactly how old it is
the records go back to twelve fifty one
but the design of our cellar is before
the turn of the century so you don't
know it's definitely older than the
others though right one ghost we've got
way more than that we've got 53 and one
in particular is way better than theirs
in 1651 James Stanley the seventh Earl
of Derby was executed right here during
the English Civil War ed
oldest pub in the world we think so but
one thing's for sure
we pull the best pint in the world wait
I haven't introduced up you there there
are many who claim to be the oldest well
we are fully researched and dated as the
oldest come on in you're very welcome
chance to bear itself is actually older
to the town itself almost all the owners
are on record even back to the original
owner Lewin himself in 900 and he guided
people across the old fort just here
over here in the walls is a letter
answered from the Guinness Book of World
Records have we found it you have found
it and you're very welcome to Shaun's
every bearers got to clear that the best
beer doors but we can certainly plan
with the best whiskey and word this has
gotta be the best excuse for a bugger
all ever
[Music]
all the machines in this arcade homemade
there's something magical about all this
as a child I found that making things
that made people laugh was satisfying
and seemed more point in doing that and
making useful machines
[Music]
I'm Tim Duncan and I'm a cartoonist and
engineer I have two arcades
one on the coasts and appear and this
one in central London called novelty
automation in total I suppose I've made
about 50 machines not many people have
that as their ambition in life but yeah
it's six feet this is petal meet you
spin the wheel and you find if the land
ends up sitting with you on the sofa or
being carved for dinner it was a hobby
that got out of control
this is Auto frisk you stand in front
here the gloves inflate and then they
act you down britain's got a great
history of satire and i suppose i'm not
really particularly political myself but
i think it's healthy for little people
to poke fun of the rich and powerful you
fly this little drone round this Beverly
Hills mansion and see all the stars
inside and your paparazzi you have to
try and take the photos to fill up the
cover of the magazine I get my ideas
from lots of places it's partly things
happening in my life partly things
happening in the news and partly from
old arcade machines and mechanisms this
is test your nerve you have to put your
hand inside the cage with the mad dog or
as long as you dare
to do something like this you have to
enjoy the process of making things I
spent most of my life solving
conventional engineering problems rather
than thinking up the jokes this is the
chiropodist you have to take off your
shoe for this one you put your foot in
the treatment Bay down the bottom and it
feels really weird seeing people
enjoying using the machines keeps me at
it and also because they take money it
provides the income to let me keep at it
so to me it's a pretty perfect system it
sure beats working I never planned my
career or anything about my life it's
just occasionally a sort of opportunity
comes up and then I go through I think
people say I look a bit like a queen in
this outfit
and people call me your majesty people
come up and they curtsy it's almost like
living two lives really let's commence
[Music]
I'm Ella slack and I'm the queen
standing I've done it for over 30 years
now anything that the Queen does is
rehearsed if it's just going to a town
hall or opening a hospital I've probably
been a standing queen definitely more
than fifty times a standing is not a
look-alike I don't look like the Queen
but I'm the same sort of stature and
height I'm about virtually 5 foot the
Queen's about 5 foot tube but I live at
royal court on Queens promenade in Royal
Ramsey in the Isle of Man and the Queen
lives in Buckingham Palace in London I
drive a Ford gear automatic car the
Queen has been seen to drive Range
Rovers and most of the time she's in a
chauffeur driven car or in a carriage
well it started because I was at the BBC
and the producer who was doing the
Cenotaph came to see me and said that
the Queen had sent a message to say when
she stood at the Cenotaph this Sun was
in her eyes and so could we do anything
about it well I said to him would you
like me to come and stand in the
position for you
because all the stage managers were six
footmen and then that led on to other
things I went in her royal carriage and
rode on the boat up to the Tower of
London and then there will be the State
Opening of Parliament I've never been
allowed to sit on on the throne and the
House of Lords I have to lurk above it
it's a very strict rule if I'm in a
carriage or a car I will wave you know
did I it's like that
the events that I've been helping with
events that are transmitted worldwide
and millions of people again to watch I
look afterwards and watch the programs
going out and I'll see her there and
think I did it for you I'm Stephen
Wiltshire hi dude joins Stephen is an
artist who creates incredibly intricate
drawings of cityscapes I love drawing
tool buildings tools skyscrapers
skylines street scenes and he does this
entirely from memory when Stephen was
three he was diagnosed as autistic he
was completely mute and lived entirely
in his own world
early on Stephens teachers noticed he
loved to draw he had found his way to
connect with others Stephen has the
ability to look at a subject once and
then draw an accurate and detailed
picture of it including panoramas of
entire cities based off just a quick
look I go up on a helicopter and then
memorize it and then after being on a
helicopter and straight back at their
hotel and then start to do taught his
incredible talent launched an artistic
career that has taken him around the
world
Los Angeles Dubai Houston Texas and
Tokyo in Japan and that's just to name a
few
New York's my favorite Empire State
Building Chrysler Building and there
lots of yellow New York taxicabs and
Stephen has no plans of stopping anytime
soon someone told me that people like me
joints feel good always being happy
about it
[Music]
[Music]
located in central London is a public
park that remains hidden to even the
locals
the medieval-style Church of sin Dunstan
in the East was built in around 1100 and
has had a long 900 year old history in
1666 it was rebuilt after being damaged
in the Great Fire of London then during
World War two a direct hit during the
London Blitz destroyed a majority of the
structure leaving behind early the north
and south walls and steeple instead of
rebuilding once again the City of London
decided to turn the remains of some
Dunstan in the east into the public
garden which is accessible today if you
know where to look
tucked away from the main road the
garden is situated between the Tower of
London and London Bridge the green Ivy
covered walls trees and flowers offer an
enchanting escape from the city and
serve as a reminder of London's history